okay hey how you doing a nice Bell hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to SCP containment breach
where we last left off I was about to
die but I'm not about to die right now
because I'm smart and good at this game
but I have completely forgotten where I
am and what I'm doing so that's new
actually that's not new that happens
absolutely every time I play a game but
for now I'm gonna get my bearings and
I'ma get right back with you because
I've completely forgotten where I am and
what I'm doing okay well this looks new
oh this looks a little different I've
been here I went in here that's right I
need the key card for that if I want the
gas mask I don't know if they've changed
up the gas mask at all the auxiliary
generator you say I can't get in there
it looks like it just kind of opens but
I'm I have no idea about that
yeah I definitely haven't been here
before okay interesting oh no it's you
Gil you sack of tit oh you big bastard
okay what are you yield your money I
knew it I had a sneaking suspicion about
that I somehow exactly knew that was
going to happen I wonder why I wonder
how high oh why are you so sad why are
you so sad come on this no need to be
sad I'm not something to be sad about I
also gotta remember to save frequently
because there's no other way to save at
the moment so I'm making my way down to
places I haven't been before oh yeah
wait no elevator up why would I knew hey
buddy why don't I need to go up why
would I be going up there's no way that
thing could possibly have followed me
all the way up here doink
oh my god you are so sassy okay goodbye
you harmless nothing
it's being sneaky oh hey it's a ghost
duck ghost a cool hello oh I thought
that was the monkey in the other room
I didn't know that I didn't know that it
was you you're spooky ghost you're so
spooky and sassy through my favorite
combinations hey why would they leave
the horribly lethal candy right out in
the open document okay a lot of
documents here I don't know why I need
these documents monkey okay each verse
sung by a cp9 8-3 appears to age the
owner of the item by what is estimated
at one year ring a ding ding ding it's
your birthday I don't know what you're
talking about I don't know man I've no
idea what you're talking about now let's
go see you hi hey how you doing they
could see you I don't like this this is
a nightmare
right in front of me this is very
clearly a nightmare very obviously just
one big nightmare yeah I need all of
these because I keep getting whomped by
radical Larry okay hey how you doing a
nice Bell something is keeping me from
new
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
delicious candy thank you for the candy
it is my birthday
good girl good girl that was fun that
was fun on a bun what did it say about
you completely Harmison a nerd under
most circumstances and maybe handle
without special precaution so long as
the handlers not experience the 24-hour
period considered the anniversary of his
birth died or met the sing-along
requirements good thing I sing sang song
the requirements oh it makes you go
older I thought that was done
differently I didn't understand that my
brain didn't keep up with that very slow
oh hi touch duck yeah like that that's a
good duck okay all right okay cool good
good you know good to know
all right lockdown lockdown yadda yadda
yadda all right good yeah well there's
no reason to be here anymore time to get
a guinea dawn which is exactly the gone
I wanted to get Oh what about you
yep nothing okay all right well goodbye
I'll see you all in there
well you suck I forgotten all how did I
forget about the thing that sneaks up
behind you randomly I don't know if they
improved it I don't think that's what I
would call improvement being more sneaky
a little more subtle I don't like it
very much but ooh
that's problem okay oh boy
well I suppose I could wait you out I
don't think there's a way that I could
draw him into the next room and get
around him before my blink Blanc turns
into a neck snap all done all done baby
oh good good talkin ta you loser yeah
you want some candies your birthday hey
there you are oh my god oh my god I have
no idea how long you need to go to be
[Music]
okay all right I can make it or I think
I can make it around you
I just gotta hurry up skadoodle my oh I
should have known that you just didn't
go away like magic just poof a fit of
smoking dust was not gone not gone at
all okay I like it because it seems a
lot less say me the areas it seems like
things are different even though there
are a lot of same areas it feels like
the layout isn't just procedurally
generated hell which it probably is but
at least I feel moderately better about
it okay oh where are you going I don't
know if this is going anywhere
fun oh yeah this no this is way oh no
this is the bow door flies but maybe
there's like some kind of item down here
that I can get okay it's gonna go
quickly scout out anything
[Music]
oh okay all right party's over thank you
for that that was awesome I don't think
there's anything down there worth
grabbing but if there is it might be
like a key card or something so I'm
gonna just save and I'm gonna go for it
yeah skin and bones I was now worth if
those not those I'm still dying I'm
still dime dime
I always sliced to ribbons to my bones
to my beefy bones my big strong oh ok so
not doing that here you guys have a
party I got to find another way because
obviously that's not gonna help me so I
need to go somewhere that's gonna have
some kind of a key card or something
either way I think I'm gonna have to
backtrack because I think I hit a bunch
of dead ends down this path I'll be back
once I find something or when something
finds me or it's something okay I think
this way leads to the way I started from
the other way is the big machine so I
think there's got to be another path
offshoot from here that I have not seen
yet anything in there probably not I
have been here haven't I I came that way
so what's down this way oh this room hmm
do you do that thing why do you do that
why do you do that like there's
something in there is there something in
there why do you do that
great you do this you do the thing why
do you do the thing right I don't think
there's anything in here that I've
missed but maybe there's got to be like
a keycard or something cuz that's the
only thing that I can think of that I
haven't got tit tit just tit it's a
bigger big tit oh you're so fast oh
that's a problem oh hey how you doing
hey Larry hey oh you bet you be you good
you good you good breath okay you're
good you're good you're good okay hi
what god kill each other Oh sucks
here we all right great oh yo just kill
me kill me you see this is why I have
trust issues this is why I don't do min
on that yeah oh my god okay I'm not
gonna go in that room up on Dee's not
it's not gonna do it I know I just
remembered that way back in the
beginning when I first did the oxygen
chamber there was a way okay there was a
way that I might be able to go oh
whatever
I also might be able to go in there but
Oh in here and here and here in this
place this place
you remember this fun place Oh see
there's stuff over here
oh oh it's dork
was very dork oh is it so dork
whoever eats new things in Infernus
custody' miss just add Imus hey this
looks familiar but I don't think I've
been here before this is yeah there's a
new area okay okay cool
good good good very good ah I like up
I like up up is good up is real good up
feels like progress down bad down very
bad up good up good up good down bad
down very bad a bad a bad a bad up good
a bad wait no I got a bad memory about
this some bad hear some bad good up good
or a bad enough looming me don't
remember I don't think I think I just
happened to run into radical where oh
you suck don't touch me don't touch me
don't touch me it's not fair real tired
real tuckered up mad up very bad good I
feel like there might have been like
some goodie Wow
I'm bad oh hey are you doing it all got
your sloughs leave so much lose I don't
like that I don't like you and I don't
like that well I'm stuck down here or
and I okay let me just check these
cabinets I'll be out of your hair just
yeah oh my god my gullet oh I hate
everything about you there's nothing
here this is all my kidney this is all
pointless point very pointless oh you
don't get me
why are you able to just go through that
is it cuz you slugged up the way you
lubed it with your slip are you still
need to run now running now would be
good oh one one health is one all I need
is one oh why you are just just the king
of bad timing I don't know where I am I
give me I didn't want to close that I
wanted to take the thing you know the
thing I don't know what I got but I need
these I need this I need that and I'm
gonna save you no screw it I don't care
if I'm backed in the corner I'm like a
wild animal
alright ring that's good I think
probably Oh duck oh that was a mistake
[Music]
hmm can I touch you back I don't like
this I don't like this makes me feel
uncomfy okay medical hype oh and what is
nothing it's a whole lot of nothing well
alright I guess this is just my life now
is it this is my life is this life oh
we're better we're all good now we're
all good
I think we're fine I must say I don't
know
medical hype oh yes okay I needed that
what happens if I was this
oh wait five hundred that's the cure-all
dammit I'm an idiot that's not what I
was I got a die I gotta go die okay
anybody in here no okay good I don't
remember which way I was running in a
panic from I feel like I hit a dead end
oh yeah I definitely hit a dead end so I
gotta go yeah but to where I do not know
I could try to go I'm just checking this
there's nothing over here I could try to
go into the tunnel that the creature
nine three nine came out of can I even
cry yeah I can't crush okay so I can
crouch maybe I could fit in there
I do not know oh why the biggest of
dongs
you suck them okay okay
oh you didn't go away did you you didn't
you don't go away right oh you just kind
of stand there and wait for me because
I'm an idiot and I'm assuming that you
just disappear into another dimension
but no you you don't do that you don't
do that you do the opposite of what that
is so great oh okay so I'm not assuming
that you're gone speaking of gone
where's that mannequin I don't know
where that was
oh no you're still there okay you just
don't go away you don't do the going
away thing do you
oh hi can you do
all right so I I definitely won't be
able to get in there but I'm but damn it
I'm gonna try here I go here I go I'm
going in the hole don't kill me
oh okay get all boyfriend
I give me in this hole
why okay
oh hey they're gone
well that's handy dandy for me all right
okay good all right so I still have the
conundrum of I don't know where I'm
going
which is as I've heard a conundrum so I
can't get down there that's a big nopon
that I there's no way I could ever get
down there which is fine I don't even
want to get down there but I do need to
figure out where else I could go that's
in that area and there's there's nothing
in there for me there's nothing all
right so this leads to the machine the
machine is down this way but was there
anything else down there that I
conveniently forgotten all about
probably okay so here is the machine the
machina very cool oh I didn't use my
medical hypo I should use that okay so
the machine here it is great I don't
know what to do about this because I've
already done everything I could possibly
do I'm gonna throw myself in I'm gonna
change me one to one oh let me in
hell yeah hell yeah
oh alright I made it and I'm totally
fine here we go nice fine I mean I'm
already fine but whatever yeah woo scrap
well I'm losing some scrap but I don't
know what else dude does about that I'm
gonna change it to very fine all right
let's do this let's get me in there
mash me up whoo more scrap you say I
think it has no idea how to deal with me
I don't think the death is programmed
from that anymore but just in case I'm
not gonna save because I don't know if
it's like gonna be a slow death I lost
all my scrap so eventually I'm gonna
fall to pieces under pressure but you
never know
there was nothing in the bathrooms I
know that Oh what Dwight the bathroom
what why the bathroom you pervert you
pervert
who you sock you pervert you perfect
pervert you big pervert pervert god
you're such a pervert stop looking at me
pay and I've still got no key card
there's just no key card warehouse has
key card
someone tell Anderson to speak with them
about it where is the warehouse where's
the warehouse
I want the warehouse there might have
been something up here that I missed did
you have a key card you have a key card
if you have a key card key card what oh
it's the ghost under that I knew that
get two candies good for me maybe
that'll heal me up a little bit not
nothing a whole lot of nothing ah okay
um I'm a bit lost I'm lost I'm lost and
I have no idea where to go to get unlost
so I'm gonna just call it for now and
what I'm probably gonna do is I'm
probably gonna have to start are you
actually going what what I have no
choice now oh please don't be here this
is exactly what I didn't watch you suck
so why did that applause
[Music]
oh it hurts real bad okay this is
inconvenient to Annette oh hi there you
I was wondering what happened to you
friend you big pervert you oh you know
what I think yeah I think that's a sign
I'm just gonna let it go for now and I'm
probably gonna start a new game because
I must have missed something somewhere
along the way and who knows who knows
okay all right cool uh anyway so thank
you everybody so much for watching there
is more SCP to discover and I think the
developers are on the way to release a
new stable build of this game with new
monsters and updated monsters and new
levels so hopefully by the time we do
the next one if you guys want one it
will be a new update to play so thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the other numerous editions of SCP
containment breach
I have played down in the description
below or in these suggested videos over
there thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]